if you want to start a habit one of the
things that works best for me is using
the concept of a watering hole if you
think about your house or where you live
there's probably a few places that you
like congregate they're like your
watering holes for me I have my desk in
my office in the kitchen table my
nightstand those are the three places
that I spend 95 percent of my time and
so if I want to start doing something
like for me I want to start putting
chapstick on my face I actually put one
ChapStick in each of my three watering
holes and so whenever I sit down at each
of them I'm reminded to do it so I don't
need to have willpower or set some alarm
on my phone which I always would
disregard after a couple of times doing
it you know what I'm talking about so
that's worked well for me maybe it'll
work well for you